We all prisoners on the universe taunts us by showing us all the places we can't
have a visit.
However,
if our species wants to have a longterm future,
we have to escape our present,
but what's keeping us here in the first place?
Turns out we are the universe.
A debt that is 4.5 billion years old.
Everything with mass in the universe as tracks,
every other thing with mass,
we call this phenomenon gravity.
The closer you are to a big chunk of mass,
the stronger the attraction or the more your call them.
This effect traps us on earth.
We can imagine this as being prisoners in a gravity present or a gravity well,
it's not a literal wealth,
but a handy concept to understand how this works.
Being in a gravity prison means that you owe gravity energy,
but how can you oh energy,
because in our universe,
things don't want to change their speed or direction to convince them to move.
You have to expand energy.
Billions of years ago,
the gravitational attraction of trillions of trillions of dust particles
orbiting our son pulled them together until they formed a planet.
This process used energy and created the gravity well.
We're now a part of the deeper you are inside a gravity well,
the more energy you,
oh gravity.
If you don't find a way to get enough energy,
you're not able to leave no matter what you do because your atoms were once part
of the data that the universe expanded energy on to get to this place.
Okay?
Let's summarize all of that again.
Objects in the universe don't like to move.
You have to convince them to do so with energy.
Gravity used energy to convince the parts that make up our Punnett to move
together.
This created a gravity prison in the process trapping us to escape it.
We need to repaired with energy.
Okay,
how do we do that?
Okay.
To get into space,
we need to go through a complicated process of exchanging energy.
For this purpose.
We build a negative potential energy repaying machines known by them or boring
name rockets.
Rockets work by using some of the most energetic chemical reactions humans know
about to basically explode,
fueled in a controlled way.
This converts chemical energy into kinetic energy.
The exhaust of the reaction is directed outwards and pushes the rocket away from
Earth by expanding a lot of energy.
We are increasing our gravitational potential energy,
which is a complicated way to say that we're paying back our energy debt to
gravity,
but it's actually a lot trickier than that.
When you burn fuel to get into all this,
you lose lots of energy to heat the exhaust and atmospheric drag,
so you actually need much more as you can't just part a huge amount of really
explosive,
dangerous for your close to your payload detonated.
You need a controlled burn,
which is complicated and makes your rocket very heavy,
which means it has more mass.
The more mass something has,
the more energy you need to convince it to move,
so you need more fuel to lift up your rocket,
but if you need more fuel,
that means you need more rocket to carry that fuel.
But this makes sure rocket heavier,
thus requiring more fuel,
which requires more rocket to carry that new fuel and so on.
At the end of this madness,
you need closer to a hundred times the weight of your payload.
To launch Ariana six for example,
the European rocket,
we'll wait 800 tons and should be able to transport 10 times into geostationary
transfer always,
or 20 tons into medium earth orbit,
but a rocket can only produce so much trust,
so there's a maximum weight after which it just won't take off.
If you add too much weight,
it won't lift off,
so you can't just build bigger and bigger fuel tax.
This is the tyranny of the rocket equation and it means space flight will never
become easy,
but wait,
it gets worse.
Getting into space is still not good enough.
You're still inside the gravity prison at the age of space and we'll crash back
to earth.
Staying in space is much harder than guessing that to get to a stable position
where it can stay for a while,
the rocket has to reach low earth orbit.
To do this,
you need a lot of kinetic energy,
which means going extremely fast at an altitude of about 100 kilometers.
This is eight kilometers per second,
28,000 kilometers per hour.
Fast enough to travel around Earth in 90 minutes.
Here.
We can use a trick.
Instead of flying straight up,
we can go sideways.
Earth is a sphere,
so if you're going sideways fast enough,
even though you're falling towards earth,
the ground,
we'll cover way beneath you.
So as long as you're above the atmosphere about 100 kilometers up,
you'll be able to stay up there in orbit.
This is what the ISS does falling around Earth,
expanding energy from time to time to stay fast enough.
If we look at Orbitz in scale,
we see that narrow earth orbit is laughably close to Earth.
To deploy,
for example,
satellites or need for other planets requires another round of energy debt
repayment.
Getting to orbit is the most difficult part of space line for us right now.
For example,
if we want to send a rocket to Mars,
half the energy is necessary just to get into orbit and the other half for the
55 million kilometers to Mars.
Therefore to be as effective as possible.
Rockets aren't built in one giant piece.
Instead,
we use multistage rockets.
You don't need to carry an empty fuel tank,
so rockets drop it.
Rockets today said their boosters and main stage as they ascend with each
successive stage being its own fully contained,
Rocky's complete with its own engine and fuel.
Okay,
so this is why getting to space is hard.
If you feel all of this seems really complicated,
don't worry.
It's literally rocket science.
This video was made possible in part by a sponsorship by Abba Saffron launches
and Ariana space who are getting their new Ariana six rocket ready to launch
into space in 2020 you can learn more about the rocket here,
and as always,
if you like what we do,
please consider supporting us on patrion.com it really helps us out a lot.
If you're craving more space stuff.
Now here's a playlist for you.